-Hi, Chelsea.
Welcome back to the show.
You look great, bud.
Thanks so much
for coming on the show,
and actually I want to thank you
for coming on the show back
when we first started doing
the show from home, from the --
where we started the quarantine,
early in the quarantine.
-Yeah, you weren't in a good way
when the quarantine started.
I remember.
You were like -- I was like, "He
better get back to work soon."
You were like, "How long am I
going to have to stay home?"
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, seriously.
I remember getting off of our
Zoom and I was like,
"Oh, he's not going
to like this.
He's not liking quarantine
at all."
-That was challenging, man.
But I did -- now I look back
and I go, "Oh, yeah, I think
it was fun, the home shows."
But I don't remember
them really.
It just like --
just happened so fast.
It was just me --
it was Nancy and I.
There was no one --
could I say me and Nancy?
Just me and Nancy.
-It's just Nancy and me
is really what you should be
saying.
I mean, I hate to constantly
go over grammar with you.
It's exhausting.
-We just started the interview.
That's one.
-I know.
-I get three strikes.
-In this interview,
you get three strikes.
In our history --
-In our history, oh, forget it.
I'm already -- oh, please.
Are you kidding me?
I'm awful.
I'm bad with that.
I've got to figure that out.
Next time I talk to you,
you can test me on grammar
and see if I'm getting better.
-All right, that sounds like
a fair shake. Thank you.
-That sounds like a really
exciting part of the interview.
-Yeah, it sounds like an episode
people are going to be
dying to see.
[ Laughs ]
-"Oh, did see the
Chelsea Grammar episode?"
-Chelsea -- [ Laughs ]
Chelsea Grammar.
I can team up with
Kelsey Grammer
and we can both double team
you on your grammar.
-Do you have your Halloween
costume yet?
If not, you could be
Chelsea Grammar.
-That's it.
-I'm just saying.
Are you a Halloween person?
I feel like you were
and now you're not.
-It's weird that you would
think that,
but I'm not into dressing up.
I feel like it's degrading.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah.
-I'm not into costumes.
You're a good sport,
and I don't have a good sport
attitude.
I'm kind of like a Scrooge when
it comes to people telling me
what to do on a certain day
of the year.
I take offense to that.
[ Laughter ]
It's like Christmas,
"No, don't tell me
when I'm supposed to give
my friends and family gifts
and celebrate something I don't
even believe in."
-I agree with you about that.
Don't tell me what you want
for Christmas.
That's the whole idea --
No, I'm giving a gift.
I'm just giving
and either you take it
or you go, 'Wow, okay.'"
-Yeah.
-You get what you get.
-This Christmas is going to be
different because like --
you know, like you, I spend
a lot of time with my family.
But I spent a lot of time,
they descended upon my house
when quarantine started.
My sister, Simone,
who I used to like a lot more,
and her three children.
They lived with me
for two months.
And that was, you know,
wonderful to see my house
being used in that way.
But it was a lot of time with
children that I chose
not to have on my own, you know?
So it felt like, wait a second,
I made the right decisions
in my life,
yet I'm being punished.
And then over the summer,
we went on like a two-week
family vacation
with my entire family.
-Aww.
-And with all my nieces
and nephews.
So for Christmas, they're like,
"What's the plan for Christmas?"
And we usually go for Canada.
I'm like, "We can't get into
Canada this year
because we're pariahs.
We can't go skiing."
I said, "So I guess everyone's
on their own this year
for COVID."
You know, we already had the
vacation at Martha's Vineyard.
And my brother actually had
the audacity to say to me,
"What about you coming East and
we all go skiing in Vermont?"
I go, "I don't think you're
getting the message.
I'm not celebrating Christmas
with you guys, okay?
I want to be alone."
-No.
You're like, "I don't go to you,
we go to a place.
But I'm not gonna go --
what are we --"
I think you're going to go.
-I'm not going to Vermont.
I'm not.
-Turns out I don't know you
at all.
-No, you don't.
It doesn't seem like --
The more we talk, the less it
seems like you know.
-I've read the books, I've seen
the specials, I watch the show.
I've watched -- I've seen
everything, the whole --
the evolution.
I'm not segueing yet, but the
evolution of your career.
I've been there.
We're getting close.
-You have.
-I have the long setup.
So I say "evolution,"
then eventually we'll get
to the setup.
But not yet.
-Okay, should I just wait here?
Should I just wait here?
-Yes.
You should just wait there.
I was thinking,
is my grammar
correct on that?
You're very open about how
therapy has helped you
become a more patient person
in some ways.
Is that something that you
have to work on
all the time and still do?
-Well, yes.
I mean, for sure.
If I could learn
how to get a handle on
my patience, anyone can.
And you know, you think you're
doing well, like I -- you know,
I'm making a lot of
improvements, I'm less reactive.
But when I came home
this last trip,
I had been gone
for like two months.
I went and shot my special,
I went on my family vacation,
then I rented a house in Maine
for a couple weeks.
And I came home and my assistant
had had all the decks
painted black,
dark, dark black.
Paint on my wood, my Ipe wood,
and my house.
And this is -- and I think, you
know, like "Oh, I'm reasonable.
I'm a rational person."
I walked outside, saw my --
and my decks, and my house,
and compass, everything.
And I went off.
I was like, "How could you think
that I would think that
this would look good?
Black paint!" I go,
"It's too hot to even walk on.
The dogs are going to scald
their little baby paws."
And then --
I couldn't believe it.
I go, "How could you think
I would like paint?"
-Yes.
-"How could you paint wood?
And how could paint it
this color?"
-"Am I a person that looks like
they like painted wood?
Don't you know me?"
-Yeah, and I looked --
And I'm like -- oh --
as soon as it's out
and I'm screaming and saying
these words
and being such a small person
and I'm worried about
my stupid decks when we're
in the middle of a pandemic,
I was like, "Shut up,
shut up, shut up,
you're being a bitch.
Shut up, shut up.
Stop talking!
Stop talking."
And I'm like, you think you're
all, you know, fixed or better
and then you have a slip-up
like that,
and that was really
embarrassing.
I had to apologize
to my assistant
'cause I had an outburst like
I hadn't had in years.
So it's a work in progress.
-Yeah, I have to call
your therapist,
'cause I have the same problem.
Did you -- let's get into
something that's less stressful.
Did you watch the debate
last night?
[ Light laughter ]
-You know what?
I took myself out to dinner
instead of watching the debate,
because I've heard that idiot
talk for four years
and I don't need to hear him
say another word.
-[ Laughs ]
-I mean, seriously.
My blood pressure,
you can already tell
when I get enervated.
It's not good for anybody.
-No.
-So I can't watch him talk.
No, thanks.
-I think --
-And you know --
-Go.
-You heard about my
ex-boyfriend, right?
50 Cent and his support
of Donald Trump?
How he tweeted about it.
-Yeah, what's going on?
I saw your tweets and I go,
"Wait, what's happening?"
'Cause you said he was your
favorite ex-boyfriend.
And then he -- what does he do?
He's supporting Trump?
-He says he doesn't want to pay
62% of taxes,
which by the way, isn't
a plan of Joe Biden's.
That's a lie.
So he doesn't want to pay
62% of taxes
because he doesn't want to go
from being 50 Cent to 20 Cent.
And I -- and I had to remind him
that he was a black person,
so he can't vote
for Donald Trump
and that he shouldn't be
influencing
an entire swath of people
who may listen to him
because he's worried about
his own personal pocketbook.
So I haven't heard back from him
yet, but I am willing to,
you know, seal the deal
in more ways than one
if he changes his mind
and publicly denounces
Donald Trump.
I might be willing to go
for another spin,
if you know what
I'm talking about.